[Music]  you used to be a crime reporter in japan  why  you think because you're a foreigner the  roads are different yeah listen you like  busting my balls huh it is a great joy  of my life  giving up and going home is not an  option you know what i mean  you know exactly what you mean  [Music]  and let me guess  this is how you recruit a cop  [Applause]  he gotcha  with information  everything you do has consequences  there there's always a costume  [Music]  jake this is sato he's not as brooding  as he seems  [Music]  what's it like to be a yakuza i could  write about that yes  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  this world  once we open the door  it is very hard to close  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  don't write about this  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you